when you think of Kingsman the Secret
Service you'll probably imagine tailored
suits gentlemen spy gadgets and Oxford's
over brogues
but now Elton John as well I'm Simon and
this is your secret agent news update
it's been revealed that Kingsman the
Golden Circle seems to have quite the
star-studded cast with actors like
Channing Tatum Halle Berry and Julianne
Moore set to appear now it looks like
we'll see classic rock singer Elton John
in the upcoming sequel as well
John posted a picture on Instagram which
revealed his involvement in the Golden
Circle the picture reads Wednesday
nights all right for fighting which is a
reference to his song Saturday Night's
Alright for fighting
Kingsman director Matthew Bourne
originally wanted celebrities to make
cameos in the first movie though he can
dit for a number of reasons including
the suspension of disbelief one needs
when a celebrity appears as himself
while other famous actors play fictional
roles he told ABC news radio that he had
a special idea for John I was arming
annoying because Kingsman had a whole
fun subplot about celebrities being
kidnapped and I had an idea of who's the
worst celebrity you'd want to have
locked in a cell and I came up with
Elton John and having Elton John
throwing these huge tantrums and then I
wanted to do an action scene of Elton
John kicking the living daylights out of
people the Kingsmen sequel is set to
open in theaters on June 16th 2017 it
stars Taron Egerton as protagonist eggsy
and sees the return of Mark Strong
Sophie Cookson and Edward Holcroft Colin
Firth's return has also been teased as
well are you excited for another
Kingsman or are you still cringing over
that sex joke ending let me know in the
comments or come find me on Twitter I'm
at the jaqen all thanks for watching and
for all your entertainment news keep it
gamespot